ihre freunde was geht ab herzlich
willkommen zu einem sehr besonderen
video für mich und allgemein auch auf
diesem kanal
ich habe in den letzten monaten etwas
sehr besonderes gemacht mir ist etwas
sehr besonderes passiert und daraus
resultiert dieses video
ich hole heute mein traumauto ab dass
ich vor zwei monaten auch schon probe
gefahren bin was ich jetzt durch aktien
in sehr kurzer zeit mehr finanzieren
konnte dazu aber später mehr
wir sind jetzt gerade schon auf dem weg
zum händler ich bin unfassbar aufgeregt
ist ein sehr modernes auto es ist ein
sehr ps starkes auto
ich bin unfassbar aufgeregt und freue
mich denn jetzt abholen zu können und
euch gleich zu erzählen wie es dazu
gekommen ist sind da freunde
ich sehe schon den ein oder haben haben
wagen ich muss jetzt hier links bleiben
weil sonst
wisst ihr schon was es wird bin die
letzten zwei jahre in köln nur mit miet
kam gefahren deswegen das jetzt auch
wirklich sinn macht für mich ein auto zu
kaufen
gerade das auto weil es trotz des hohen
anschaffungspreises langfristig extrem
günstig ist vielleicht könnt ihr schon
so ein bisschen erahnen was es sein
könnte
ich will gar nicht länger drumrum reden
weil das so lange ich rede desto länger
bin ich noch von meinem auto entfernt
lasst uns die karte abholen
[Musik]
kann die beiden jungs leider nicht mit
rein nehmen aufgrund von rona darf nur
allein rein aber jetzt ist es
anscheinend so weit bin so fucking
aufgelegt
[Musik]
ja ja ja langsam solltet ihr schon
verstehen um was für ein auto sich haben
sind aber welches genau das erfahrt ihr
nach dem ich erzählt habe wie das hier
alles zustande gekommen ist komplett
krank in anderen videos habe ich ja
schon mal anklingen lassen dass sie ins
upgrades wie wall street betz unterwegs
bin und genau damit startet und endet
auch diese geschichte mit dem november
weiß mal wieder am durch scrollen und
habe mir einfach ein paar beiträge
durchgelesen
dabei ist mir dann auch einen beitrag
von gamestop untergekommen ich habe euch
mal in die video beschreibung verlinkt
was da jetzt insgesamt so passiert ist
ich werde nicht genau darauf eingehen
check den link in der video
beschreibungen da erklärt dass jemand
professionell auf jeden fall habe ich
dann ende november das allererste mal
gamestop aktien gekauft zu einem preis
von 14 euro 30 habe ich insgesamt 1500
euro investiert das ganze habe ich dann
ein bisschen aus den augen verloren und
mitte januar habe ich gesehen dass das
plötzlich mehr als doppelt so viel wert
waren die aktie hatte 111 prozent plus
gemacht und ich habe sie verkauft weil
ich dachte wow ich habe mein geld in so
kurzer zeit verdoppelt ich habe gar
nichts mehr davon mitbekommen ich habe
einfach kostenlos so viel geld bekommen
hat das alles liegen lassen und habe
mich dann in den nächsten tagen davon
aber nicht mehr richtig lösen können und
habe immer wieder dran gedacht war was
was war das das ab das hat sich so
komisch angefühlt
und dann habe ich mir die zeit genommen
um mich noch mal richtig in das thema
einzuarbeiten das war dann so um den 17
januar das sich wirklich wieder
angefangen habe mich da rein zu lesen
und zu schauen was da gerade so phase
ist zu dem zeitpunkt ist die aktie auch
schon immer weiter gestiegen und war
schon über 30 euro wert nachdem ich das
für ein paar tage gemacht habe habe ich
einen sehr klassen entschluss gefasst
und dieses video aufgenommen hallo
freunde wir haben den 21 20 21 und
nachdem ich in den letzten wochen
schon einmal gamestop aktien gekauft
habe und die dann mit 100 prozent
verkauft habe habe ich mich heute dazu
entschieden doch noch mal nach zu kaufen
und hat neue aktien gekauft und zwar
nicht so ein bisschen mit dem kompletten
geld was mir zur verfügung steht
das ist scheinbar für viele extrem dumm
dass können wenig leute nachvollziehen
ich glaube aber daran es ist kein
youtube projekt oder so ich halte das
hier einfach nur fest falls ein wunder
geschieht
ich habe niemandem davon erzählt weil
mir jede davon abraten würde und ich
habe niemandem davon erzählt weil jeder
ansonsten meine meinung anzweifeln würde
in zukünftigen sachen wenn es um aktien
oder so geht ja jetzt heißt es warten
und hoffen dass sich was tut aber ich
halte es nur ganz kurz festhalten
einundzwanzigste erster 20 21 16.000
euro im gamestop aktien für einen preis
von 33 euro komplett verrückt vielleicht
ein bisschen dumm ein bisschen naiv oder
sehr naiv
ich habe den leuten bei denen ich diesen
ganzen kram im internet gelesen habe
ziemlich blind vertraut und mich davon
mitreißen lassen das hat sich für mich
schlüssig angehört aber ich bin kein
aktienexperte ich verstehe nicht genau
was da abgeht aber dieses diese energie
hat mich gepackt und ich habe mich dafür
entschieden für 16.000 euro da eben
aktien zukaufen komplett verrückt in den
nächsten tagen konnte ich nicht mal mehr
vernünftig arbeiten ich habe wirklich
den ganzen tag nur auf den chart geguckt
der glücklicherweise die ganze zeit hoch
gegangen ist was die folge hatte dass
ich einen oder zwei tage später die
aktie direkt mit 100 prozent wieder
teilweise verkaufen konnte so konnte ich
nach zwei tagen die hälfte meiner aktien
verkaufen und immer noch denselben wert
bringen haben also habe ich quasi mein
einsatz nach zwei tagen raus geholt und
mit dem gewinnen das ganze weiter laufen
lassen um komplette sicherheit für mich
zu haben und trotzdem weiter teil davon
zu sein in den nächsten tagen ging es
dann ziemlich rund mal bergauf mal
bergab aber eigentlich konstant sehr
schnell sehr krass bergauf ich habe
angefangen damit sehr emotional zu
werden
sehr politische gedanken dabei zu haben
das als was größeres zu sehen als nur
eine pump action
das ist mir wirklich extrem nah gegangen
und ich habe da meine komplette zeit
rein gesteckt ohne dass sich natürlich
irgendeinen einfluss auf den chart haben
konnte ist die zeit komplett darauf
flöten gegangen
irgendwelche beiträge zu sehen die news
abzuchecken den chart zu folgen
glücklicherweise ist die aktie die ganze
zeit gestiegen und alles war positiv
dann sind ein paar super krasse sachen
passiert wie dass es den leuten nicht
möglich war weitere aktien zukaufen bei
manchen programmen
das war wirklich ein drunter und drüber
da werde ich nicht weiter darauf
eingehen
die aktie ist weiter gestiegen und als
dann papa ihnen sich dafür entschieden
hat darüber zu treten ist die aktie
absolut durch die decke gegangen auf bis
zu 180 euro glaube ich an den tag und
ich habe mich dafür entschieden folgen
mein herz du hast doch jetzt geht ja
hofmannsthals klocke marktpreis damit
jan knopf drückt
[Musik]
ich hab aber wirklich komplett gänsehaut
alter jammer jammer
das ist wirklich das kristalline ganz
jedem dennoch drin ist und weiter es ist
wirklich so dass ich mich so ein
bisschen schuldig fühle jetzt nicht
weiter zu halten aber dicker ich habe
mit 16.000 angefangen und ich hab jetzt
wenn ich das richtig sehe so 58.000 nach
sechs oder sieben tagen waren die
investierten 16.000 euro dann 58.000
euro wert ist wird es immer noch
komplett wird an darüber zu sprechen
ich habe auch länger überlegt euch das
video machen sollen oder nicht aber ich
dachte die story war zu gut um sie euch
vorzuenthalten
ich habe mich dann dafür entschieden
dass mit diesem gelten geld ich mir was
gerne und habe mich dafür entschieden
quasi instant einen tag später mein
traumwagen zu bestellen und bevor ich
euch den zeigen möchte ich euch von
meinem partner erzählen der es wird zum
einen vereinfacht hat mein auto zu
versichern und zum anderen dieses video
unterstützt worüber ich sehr dankbar
wenn clark ist ein komplett kostenlose
versicherungsmanager der euch dabei
hilft den besten überblick über eure
versicherung zu behalten und eure
vielleicht veralteten versicherung in
neue umzuwandeln ihr könnt also quasi
eure bestehenden versicherung einfach
hochladen und klagt sucht euch die beste
und passendste versicherung für euch
raus so könnt ihr quasi kostenlos geld
sparen und gleichzeitig dabei den
besseren versicherungsschutz genießen
ohne irgendwelche dummen papierkram
ausfüllen zu müssen das ganze
funktioniert super easy über die app
quasi genau wie meine auto bestellung
das hat also sehr gut gepasst ich bin
kein großer freund davon altmodisch
irgendwas hin und her zu faxen irgendwas
mit briefen zu schicken diesen ganzen
stress habt ihr bei clark nicht das
funktioniert super easy einfach so über
die app und ich bin extrem happy darüber
dass sieben mich bei diesem projekt
unterstützen weil es super gut passt und
weil ich die app selber genutzt habe für
die versicherung meines autos außerdem
hat das placement hier natürlich auch
noch ein vorteil für euch wenn ihr über
den ersten link in der video
beschreibung die app runterladen könnt
ihr bis zu drei versicherungen unter dem
code wave angeht
und dafür 1 45 auch amazon gutschein
zurückbekommen ist quasi eine
win-win-win-situation ich bin sehr sehr
froh dass ich mich an dieses video
unterstützen könnt euch die app check
teure versicherung es geht dabei um eure
sicherheit jetzt aber weiter zu meinem
traum auto und der abholung meines
trauer komplett verwirkt genauso ist es
passiert und jetzt ist es soweit hier
stehen unfassbar viele keilholz ja
verrückt ich kann das wirklich nicht
glauben ich kann es wirklich nicht
glauben
oh mein gott wirklich vielen dank an
tesla köln im carlswerk die haben es mir
super einfach gemacht den wagen probe zu
fahren den zu bestellen denn innerhalb
von drei wochen zu erhalten komplett
verrückt wie schnell das ging das so
funktioniert hat also vielen dank an die
jungs und mädels von tesla köln im
carlswerk ich habe ich den link in die
video beschreibung gepackt da könnt ihr
über meinen linken tesla bestellen oder
auch einfach kostenlos mit probefahrt
machen das super easy unverbindlich
kostet nix check das auf jeden fall ab
ist natürlich nichts bezahlt ist oder so
nicht sagt es einfach nur weil es
wirklich so reibungslos funktioniert hat
und dass so ein spaß gemacht hat der
gesamte prozess war super super super
krass es ist unglaublich für mich war ja
das ist wirklich böses unglaublich
wirklich einfach mal anpacken
[Musik]
schonmal bürgers
stimmen
[Musik]